So the last integrative therapy that we'll discuss today is called dialectical
behavior therapy which uses a combination of cognitive behavioral therapy and
mindfulness but without the meditation element. This is a common treatment for
borderline personality disorder. And the idea here is that in this treatment,
the person will earn to accept without judgement their actions and their
emotions. And if this occurs, then they can have a great reduction in self harm
behaviors, in substance abuse, and risk for suicide, and depression. And these
are all common symptoms in borderline personality disorder. And dialectic
behavior therapy can also be used in treating eating disorders, conduct
disorders, and domestic violence.